'S TEAM ON THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY IS OFF TO A PRETTY ROCKY
START, AND THE TWO FRONT RUNNER
RUNNERS, CREEPY UNCLE JOE AND
BERNIE SANDERS ARE FACING A
LITTLE BIT OF RECKONING AS
QUESTIONS WERE ALL NOW ABOUT THE
COVETED OBAMA ENDORSEMENT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
THAT OBAMA HAD URGED CRAZY UNCLE
JOE NOT TO RUN IN 2016.
WELL, SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS IS
IN SOME HOT WATER TONIGHT.
NEW DOCUMENTS AND PHOTOS
REVIEWED BY FOXNews.com
REVEALS THAT HE HAS A HISTORY OF
PRAISING VIOLENT SOCIALIST
REVOLUTIONARIES AND POLICIES
SUCH AS FORCED LAND
REDISTRIBUTION, LIKE IN CUBA.
THE AUTHOR OF A BRAND-NEW BOOK
JUST OUT TODAY.
IT IS ON Hannity.com,
BOOKSTORES EVERYWHERE.
IT'S CALLED "COLLUSION."
IF THAT IS NOT RIPPED FROM THE
HEADLINES --
>> SOMETIMES YOU GET LUCKY.
>> Sean: YOU WILL BE AT BOOK
ENDS AT 6:00 TOMORROW EASTERN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I DON'T SEE YOU IN STUDIO MUCH.
IT WAS COLLUSION.
IT WAS PEERING OUT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," TWO AND A
HALF YEARS OF LYING.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT WAS PROBABLY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
>> IS THIS GOING TO BE WILD?
IT TURNS OUT THAT ENTIRE DOSSIER
WAS UPLAND BY THE RUSSIANS?
>> Sean: MR. SPEAKER, THEY
NEVER VERIFIED IT, AND THEY USED
IT IN THE APPLICATIONS, AND IT
WAS A BACKDOOR.
>> IF YOU KNEW TRUMP WAS BAD,
WHY WOULD YOU VERIFY IT?
IT FIT ALL OF YOUR PREVIOUS
BELIEFS.
>> Sean: YOU SAY THAT WITH A
SMILE.
THAT'S AN ATTEMPT -- REMEMBER --
>> IT'S A COUP D'ETAT.
HE WAS INTERVIEWED.
IT IS SORT OF A TWO-WAY STREET.
BUT HIS COMMENTS, THE NEWS MEDIA
REACTED TO AS THEY DID BECAUSE
THEY ARE HIS ENEMIES.
THIS WAS AN ATTEMPTED COUP
D'ETAT.
THIS WAS AN EFFORT BY A GROUP OF
PEOPLE TO UNDERMINE THE CHOICES
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE
THEY HAD SAID THAT THEY WERE
MORALLY SUPERIOR AND THEY HAD
THE CHOICE TO DENY US THE
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM.
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
>> Sean: I LOOK AT IT IN THREE
DIFFERENT PHASES.
PHASE ONE, HILLARY'S
INVESTIGATION WE KNOW WAS
RIGGED.
THEY ARE LAUGHING ABOUT IT.
IT IS NOT AN INVESTIGATION.
ON THE TARMAC.
THEY ARE SAYING TOUGH.
HIS AFFIXES IN.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT.
NOW, THE NEXT PIECE OF IT, THE
ATTEMPT TO SPY AND RIG AN
ELECTION.
WITH WHAT THEY GOT OFF THE HOOK.
TO THEN UNDERMINE A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT WITH THOSE RUSSIAN
LIES.
>> I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
TO HAVE THE NERVE TO CALMLY AND
METHODICALLY YOU GET EVERYTHING
OUT IN THE OPEN.
LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE HOW
SICK THE SYSTEM HAS GONE.
>> Sean: WE KNOW THE PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU CAN'T RIG AN INVESTIGATION
FOR YOUR FAVORITE CANDIDATE.
YOU CAN PRESENT TO A FISA COURT,
ONE CANDIDATE IS BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER NOT VERIFIE
VERIFIED.
THEY TELEVISED IT.
>> TODAY OR YESTERDAY, THEY
THINK CORRUPTION IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM.
WELL, THEY ARE RIGHT.
THIS IS ALL A CORRUPT BEHAVIOR
BY A POWER STRUCTURE, PART OF
THE NEWS MEDIA.
PART OF THE POLITICIANS AND
LOBBYISTS, BUT OF POWER
STRUCTURE THAT DECIDED IT COULD
PROTECT ITS FAVORITE.
IT COULD PROTECT DELL MIGHT
DESTROY THE PERSON IT DISLIKES.
IT COULD DO IT ALL OUTSIDE THE
LAW IN NO WAY THAT IS CLEARLY A
TOTAL VIOLATION.
>> Sean: YOU ARE A GREAT
HISTORIAN.
HOW DOES THIS HAPPEN?
>> THE SYSTEM HAS GROWN STEADILY
AND STEADILY MORE CORRUPT.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST BURDEN
JOE BIDEN WILL CARRY.
HE IS PART OF THE CORRUPT
SYSTEM.
HE'S GOT TWO ANSWERS.
EITHER I WAS IN THE ROOM AND
KNEW IT, OR NOBODY WOULD EVER
TELL ME.
ONE ANSWER --
>> Sean: WELL, HE WAS IN THE
ROOM.
>> I THINK HE KNEW IT, AND I
THINK THE FACT IS THAT JOE BIDEN
AND ROCCO BOUGHT        ROCCO BD
AND ROCCO BOUGHT        ROCCO BN
AND ROCCO BOUGHT        ROCCO B-
>> Sean: WE SEE THIS CAST OF
CHARACTERS.
SUPPORTING THE NEW GREEN DEAL.
ELIMINATE THE COMBUSTION.
OIL AND GAS.
COWS.
I'M SORRY, IT'S NOT ME.
I'M NOT PROPOSING IT.
>> Sean: IT'S NOT CHRISTMAS,
AND THEY RUSHED UP TO YOU WITH
THIS GIANT BOX AND SAID
PLEASE --
>> Sean: DON'T TELL ANYBODY.
IT'S OUR SECRET.
>> Sean: THE CANDIDATES ARE
SAYING THAT THEY SUPPORT THIS.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE NOBODY YET HAS
GONE TO THEIR DISTRICTS AND SAID
LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU HOW REALLY
STUPID THIS IS.
>> Sean: WELL, OKAY.
YOU'VE GOT 100 DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE AND THE HOUSE THAT LIKE
IT.
YOU HAVE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
I LIKE IT.
TWO QUESTIONS.
WHO IS GOING TO WIN THIS
PRIMARY?
DO YOU THINK IT'S BIDEN?
SANDERS?
SOMETHING ELSE?
>> THE MAYOR?
I'M TRYING.
I THINK HE HAS THE BEST CHANCE
BECAUSE HE IS THE MOST LIKE
JIMMY CARTER.
HE'S A BLANK SLATE.
EVERYBODY CAN PRETEND THEY LIKE
HIM WITHOUT EVER KNOWING WHAT HE
REALLY STANDS FOR.
HE WILL ALWAYS BE LIKE NUMBER
THREE OR NUMBER FOUR UNTIL THEY
GET TO THE VOTE.
>> Sean: WHO DO YOU THINK
WOULD BE THE TOUGHEST FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
YOU ALWAYS VOTE PEACE AND
PROSPERITY.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD A BETTER
ECONOMY.
>> I KNOW HOW MUCH THE PRESIDENT
LIKES YOU, SOUTH I'M A LITTLE
CAUTIOUS TO SAY THIS BECAUSE HE
WILL PROBABLY SEE THIS.
>> Sean: OH, BOY.
>> THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE HER TO
HIS REELECTION IS DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: WHY?
>> BECAUSE WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
DISCIPLINE AND FOCUS, HE WOULD
BECOME UNBEATABLE.
>> Sean: THERE'S NEVER BEEN --
YOU ARE THE GREAT HISTORIAN.
YOU CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN SOMEBODY
THAT IS THIS MUCH OF A
DISRUPTER.
I THINK HE IS GREATEST GIFT IS
KEEPING HIS WORD.
HE FIGHTS -- EVERYTHING HE SAID
HE WOULD DO, HE IS DOING.
>> I KEEP TELLING PEOPLE, BIDEN
WANTS TO RUN AS MR. LIKABLE
PLEASANT GUY.
TRUMP WILL RUN AS MR. TOUGH GUY
WHO GETS THINGS DONE.
THAT'S HOW YOU DO THINGS IN
THEIR REAL LIFE.
DO YOU WANT IS NICE, PLEASANT
DOOFUS, OR THIS TOUGH GUY WHO
HAS WEAKNESSES, BUT BY GOD, HE
GETS THINGS DONE.
>> Sean: HOW ABOUT MORE
AMERICANS IN POVERTY AND ON FOOD
STAMPS?
>> I DOUBT THAT WILL GET TO THAT
POINT WHERE THE BIDEN BECAUSE HE
WILL FALL APART.
YOU CAN PLAY THIS LATER ON.
>> Sean: WELL, OKAY.
WE MIGHT DO THAT JUST FOR FUN.
WELL, COLLUSION.
RIPPED RIGHT FROM THE HEADLINES.
YOU WILL BE AT THE BOOKSTORE AT
6:00 TOMORROW.